we all have evolved abilities to try and
control other people hello and welcome
to trigonometry I'm Frances lobster I'm
Constance and kissin and this is a show
for you if you're bored with people
arguing on the internet subjects they
know nothing about a trigonometry we
don't pretend to be the experts we ask
the experts are brilliant guess this
week is one of our favorite ever guests
and favorite ever human beings on the
planet
she's an evolutionary psychologist dr.
Donna Fleischman welcome back to
trigonometry happy well you genuinely
why I mean if you haven't seen enough
for a first interview with Diana go back
and watch it is absolutely brilliant was
quite early in the day for the show and
genuinely was a great pleasure which is
why we're delighted to have you back
yeah which is why it pains me to ask the
first question that I'm gonna ask which
is I've met some people recently who I
told that I do the show who I haven't
seen for many years and I mentioned that
we've had some evolutionary
psychologists on and the reaction that I
got was literally like I'd advocated for
resurgence of the Third Reich so why is
it the evolutionary psychology has a bad
rap because the argument that particular
person was making it's all about
reinforcing gender stereotypes it's all
about getting women back in the kitchen
where they belong getting women back in
the kitchen barefoot so I do think that
people have this impression that
evolutionary psychology is reactionary
because it says that many of the gender
roles and the patterns that you see
cross culturally especially between men
and women are a natural state of affairs
so they would say potentially that some
sex roles like things that women are
more nurturing and that men seek status
things that I talked about also in the
first interview are less malleable than
one might think
and if you advocate that something is
less malleable than say more cret
progressed progressive people or social
psychologists might say then they the
implication is that that's how you wish
it to be right and I'm just saying that
these sex roles and gender roles that
you see cross culturally they are the
way they are and they are fairly
universe
Sol and that's not how I want it to be
that is how I think it is and in my view
if you want something to be a certain
way you have to know how it is to begin
with and so I think all the wishful
thinking in the world about what men and
women are like is actually not going to
change what men and women are like I
mean there are some narratives that I
think are important another reason that
I think people don't like evolutionary
psychology is because that there are
some very popular evolutionary
psychologists who are well known like in
you know the social sphere so Steve
Pinker Jeffrey Miller my partner me
we're a little bit louder on Twitter
than other people but there's also been
some controversy about people for
example there's a researcher called
Satoshi Kanazawa and Satoshi works at
the London School of Economics and he
wrote a paper that said something to the
effect of black women are less
attractive because they have higher
testosterone something to that effect
and it was even it was a very odd thing
to say it was an odd blog I don't think
that he thought that it was going to be
perceived as racist because that was not
very smart on his part so these are the
evolutionary psychologists that people
are more likely to hear about are those
people who have very strong political
views right and the people who are just
getting on with their work and doing
stuff that is you know some really
amazing work that people are doing
oftentimes in the service of very
progressive causes there's even you know
a survey from about 12 years ago done by
Josh Tiber another evolutionary
psychologist who works undiscussed and
Jeffrey Miller
showing that on average people who take
adaptation esteem evolutionary or of
psychology like evolutionary
psychologists tend to be left-leaning
most of these people are left-leaning
but those are not the people that people
commonly hear about so they think about
evolutionary psychology and they think
about some very controversial stuff even
though that's not you know what the
mainstay of evolutionary psychology is
and finally I just think yeah this
evolutionary psychology kind of goes
against this malleability argument which
the progressives don't like and then it
also compares people to animals and says
we are very much like non-human animals
right we do things we know eat and [ __ ]
and have sex
and and and have normal responses that
others have and we are you know as I'll
say in this lecture I'm giving tonight
you know we're machines they were
designed by natural selection to do very
things like find mates find food etc and
people think this undermines human
dignity so the right wing also doesn't
like that and the left wing doesn't like
that this idea that we are essentially
machines designed by natural and sexual
selection and the focus on sex you know
there's a lot of reasons why people have
a have a problem with it so I think that
if people really understood that
evolutionary psychology is really just
using the lens of evolution to come up
with hypotheses about human behavior and
human nature and if they just thought
okay these people they they come up with
hypotheses these things can get
falsified etc then there wouldn't be
such a you know rabble about it as there
is now about evolutionary psychology
either being evil and reactionary or a
pseudoscience if people knew more about
what the mainstream was like so do you
think part of the problem with the way
the progressives perceive evolutionary
psychology is simply because you're
denying their reality that we're all the
same there are no differences between us
yeah the reality the idea that the
progressives have which I really have a
lot of empathy for the idea that if you
actually make a narrative that people
will stick to it so if there's a
narrative that we are all the same it's
actually going to make it more likely to
be real because as humans narratives
actually form part of how we perceive
the world and actually how we act in the
world if you have a teacher who thinks
that you're especially gifted even if
you you know have an IQ of 80 right you
then you're gonna do much better than if
you have a teacher who has more
realistic expectations of you shall we
say this even happens in relationships
right there's actually evidence that
positive delusions improve relationships
I had a huge argument with an
ex-boyfriend about this actually where
we ended up both doing a deep dive and I
said if you're deluded about how good I
am we're actually going to have a better
relationship he said cool I'm gonna
cultivate positive delusions so there's
a different there's a
the attention here between truths and
actually what you know could be
beneficial for people but if from my
view we are getting to the point in
society and science where we actually
have to understand what the baseline is
we have to understand what differences
actually happen in order to understand
how to make things different and I've
talked about myself as being an
evolutionary psychologist and also being
a transhumanist so transhumanism is the
idea that we can use technology to
improve ourselves right that we can use
technology to augment our cognition to
improve our morality even very
interesting paper that I talked about
where people say that they would
actually rather improve their language
ability or improve their memory than
they would be likely to want to improve
their morality people are it's very
weird actually if you say would you like
to take a pill to improve the number of
hours of sleep that you get per night
would you like to be able to get by on
less sleep would you like to be able to
have better memory people say that they
would take a pill for that people are at
least likely to say that they would take
a pill to improve their moral views
right but it's not as well because if we
have a high level of morality that in a
sense and limits us and it limits our
choices yes
so people as I think I talked about last
time I said why do women like bad boys
people like potentially exploitative men
because it's important in a society
where many people are potentially
exploitative to have some of that
yourself I think also people don't want
to be disadvantaged in relation to other
potentially exploitative people and so
being exploitative is sort of positional
in that sense you want to be a bit more
exploitative than the average person you
want to be a little bit less moral or be
able to exploit moral loopholes a bit
better than the average person you know
no matter how good you think you are and
we have this moral view we think that
we're more moral than other people
[Laughter]
people think on average that they're
more moral than that than other people
and even if you were to ask them you
know how moral is somebody like like a
vegan or mother Teresa or somebody who
never flies or whatever depending on
what your moral views are you would be
likely to say that those people are
still less moral than you are although
they might be more moral
average person but to get back to your
question you know this kind of
progressive view about malleability yes
that's part of it but part of is also as
I will talk about I'm giving a talk
about this tonight and I don't also in
Ghent is that people really buck against
control so Gina rip on who I did a sort
of debate against on john stossel's
youtube i said you know she and i went
back and forth we weren't in the same
room but she wrote a really interesting
book which is called the gendered brain
I think and it's interesting in that it
it's there's a lot of sofas tree in the
book unfortunately she's a very nice
woman I think that she has really great
aspirations but her book is terrible
she's just like she's really critical of
some feels and then she's not at all
critical of something like stereotype
threat which has not been replicated at
all but in any case so she says
something to the effect of there's no
structure or pattern that distinguishes
male brains from female brains and
that's not true if you look at a bunch
of different structures in the brain you
can actually distinguish a male brain
from a female brain with about 80%
accuracy and it doesn't even matter that
much because you wouldn't be able to
distinguish a physics professor from a
murderer of looking at their brains that
doesn't mean they're not different right
it's just it just means that our brain
science or the ability to distinguish
people based on brain structures isn't
very good but I think that what people
are really bucking against as a society
is this progressive idea that there are
people in power and that there's a
hierarchy and they're trying to take
advantage of other people it's all about
power in this sense and I think that
something that is really atrophying our
ability for science to actually make
headway is our desire to not be
controlled so people don't want you to
be able to guess anything about them
based on whether or not they're male or
female so now people are saying that
they're non-binary or that they had
these other very complex gender
attributes because they don't want you
to be able to say okay I'm gonna have a
very good idea of what your your
attributes are like people I was even in
arguments on on Twitter and other social
media lately where they said you
couldn't actually tell above chance
whether or not somebody was likely to
have some
chuckle conditions more or less based on
their ethnicity or if you could it was
because of the discrimination and the
social pressures that they faced
actually so I talk about being an
evolutionary psychologist and a
transhumanist because I think that the
best way to equalize our society and to
make some people better off then who are
currently worse off is actually through
technology and through biological
engineering rather than through changing
perceptions there's only so far that
changing perceptions about who can do
what can actually do unfortunately and I
think everybody is given a kind of
genetic lottery ticket some people are
born attractive some people are born
smart some people born with really good
willpower sometimes we were joking about
it but to me there's a really serious
side to what you're saying and the
problem that I find with progressivism
is you're engaging essentially in a lie
it might be a well-meaning lie but it is
still a lie and if you are lying about
who you are fundamentally that is a way
to make yourself deeply deeply miserable
I think I get what you're saying but I
don't entirely agree so I think that
there are some things that we can all be
diluted about that are kind of important
for everybody to be deluded about right
the idea that you can be anything and do
anything on an individual level this
kind of what they call the growth
mindset we are incredibly limited by our
genetic potential and the kind of hand
that we're dealt when we're born but if
you were to think about that
realistically all the time it would be
really bad right I don't really think
that humans have free will I think that
we live in a deterministic universe and
I think that humans are part of that but
the idea that you can change your
behavior
it's it's true that if you tell people
we live in a deterministic universe they
start to think things like it's less
important to act morally or it's less
important to be good to other people so
it is true that some degree of self
deception and deception I think is good
but I think if we are going to make
headway in terms of science that that
deception can't be circulated by the
people who are the experts
it can't be circulated that
for example some ethnic disparities in
health are entirely due to social stigma
and discrimination we have to understand
that men and women have biological
psychological differences and that
genetics also have a very strong
determining factor in our psychology not
just you know in interior individually
but also potentially between populations
this is all stuff that's super important
and if we don't get that we're gonna
keep trying to make interventions that
don't work well this is the interesting
thing like I watched a bit of Joe
Rogan's podcast every now and again this
is one of the things he's someone who's
definitely advocating for people to have
a growth mindset on the one hand but on
the other hand there are times when that
ideology clashes with the reality so for
example a guy who's never fought in the
Ultimate Fighting Championship the UFC
like suddenly decides that he can do it
and he goes in and gets his ass kicked
because there's a limitation to that
mindset but equally it's useful to have
an on individual level anyway let's move
on to talk about your upcoming book yeah
which is called how to train your
boyfriend my girlfriend is never getting
I'm sending it to her directly I'll be
in the post daily yeah anyway I we got a
chance to listen to you talk about it
you send us an advance copy it's
fascinating stuff
I think it's something that you know
you've gendered it for reasons that
we'll get into yeah but generally
speaking I think every human being in
the world is interested in essentially
getting other people to do what they
want if you put a crudely like that
right there's lots of stuff that that we
all want you know so I tell us a little
bit about of you know what the angle is
and some of the kind of maybe practical
applications like how do you get your
podcast pardon so stop frowning during
engine you know what would be the best
way to do that so I've been reading a
ton of BF Skinner who is a very famous
with the most famous behaviorist
basically and he was probably the most
famous psychologist for some period of
time you know behind Freud and he just
had really you know fascinating ideas a
lot of these ideas that I've just told
you about control for example that
people really buck against control and
that's part of what's addling the
science of psychology come
Skinner but to how to turn your
boyfriend so the basic idea is that we
all have evolved abilities to try and
control other people we all have evolved
the ability to use reinforcement and
punishment to try to control other
people and because we lived in an
environment you know that was we had
very little attention to break off we
had lots of other things that we're
taking our attention we had limited
amounts of time we were trying often to
use the quickest dirtiest way to control
other people and that is often
punishment so one of the main ideas is
that people overuse punishment and they
under use reward when they're
interacting with other people and
there's this very common idea that
punishment doesn't work it absolutely
doesn't otherwise we would one reason
this is a tautology but one reason is
that we actually wouldn't be so inclined
to punish other people so how to turn
your boyfriend is essentially trying to
appeal to women's self interests about
how to try and get what they want
but also it's a way of trying to limit
something that I call the alpha which is
the part of your mind that is actually
very intent on controlling the behavior
of other people and controlling the
behavior of other people has been very
important throughout our evolutionary
history and we're not very good at it in
part because we actually can't really be
cognizant we're not consciously
controlling other people the more you
consciously control other people the
more other people are going to resist
your control so if I tell you
Constantine you really need to go on a
vacation let me tell you my package to
Cancun right right you're gonna take my
you're gonna be more cynical or
skeptical of me if I have some self
interest and so if we're not aware of
her self-deceived about our
self-interest and controlling other
people then we're going to be much
better at it but another aspect of this
this idea about control is that the best
punishments and reinforcements happen
very soon after a behavior within
milliseconds if not you know within
under a second of that behavior and so
if you are hyper aware this is the same
kind of thing as the you know take your
hand off the stove principle right if
you think this stove is hot I should
remove my hand by the time you thought
all of that your hand is completely
burned and this
waise if you do a behavior that I like
or I don't like right
if I deliberate about whether or not
it's a good behavior for me or not
rather than that I would just have an
emotion and instantly punish you or
reinforce you and I do think that this
is a lot of the way humans behave to one
another especially in romantic
relationships because those were such
high stakes situations especially for
women and so men as I I talked about is
is that men have always had an ability
to control other people in a very simple
way and that is either through force or
threat of force right I mean big men
especially have this ability whereas
women have not really had this capacity
as much and so they had to develop more
sophisticated methods and so women a
better at it I mean my view is that
women are better at it and they spend
more time considering it and you know
certainly I went on a 10-day meditation
retreat in Hertfordshire
I really recommend meditation retreats
because you get an idea if you're on a
what they call a dopamine fast you have
like you're very very significantly
bored a lot of the time you've got
nothing to keep your attention you got
no youtube you got no phone you got no
books you have no conversation you are
really in this very austere environment
and what is it that you're thinking
about all the time when you're in this
austere environment well I mean I asked
a bunch of the women that I was on
meditation retreat with and they often
think about conflicts they had with
other people they think about
conversations things that they should
have said or should not have said ways
that they should have engaged with other
people people that they should have
forgiven or not and to me what's
happening in your brain when it's devoid
of stimulation a lot is thinking about
how you could better or your regrets
about social control but one thing I
found really interesting about well
there are many things but one thing in
particular was these women who had a
highly developed sensory alpha and we're
very good at it were far more likely to
pass on their genes and women who
weren't yes so the main idea that I have
here is that it's it's definitely an
evolutionary psychology kind of argument
is that that women are not built in a
way that's like eat it easy to please
and unlikely to care about the behavior
of their partner because those kinds of
women who didn't care about those things
they didn't actually try and control the
behavior of their partner would have
more likely been evolutionary dead ends
so we talk about this a lot in
evolutionary psychology even though it's
it's a difficult thing to actually prove
which is something called the mismatch
hypothesis and the idea is that our
modern environment differs in many
fundamental ways from our ancestral
environment and the ancestral
environment is not just whatever cavemen
or whatever whatever movie you want to
think about it right it's also the whole
history of mammalian evolution it's also
all of the the hominids that led up to
us right so that's our environment of
evolutionary adaptiveness and one of the
main differences in that's in those
environments is that those environments
were much more dangerous they were much
more stressful and the stakes of whether
or not you are going to be able to have
living children were much higher and so
in my view with the way we engage in
relationships especially the way that
women engage with men is often as if
whether or not you took out the rubbish
is a life or death situation because if
you are with a man who actually doesn't
consider your needs or who is neglectful
another weird mismatch is to not see
somebody all day every day or not see
anybody interacting with other people
that's a very strange mismatch as well
but if you don't see a man engaging
competently with your needs then that's
going to be something that's going to be
upsetting even though it's no longer a
life-or-death situation
hi guys we're really excited to have a
brand new sponsor at trigonometry
welcome back to the my bedroom or as
it's called in the business Alessio
Orgazmo welcome ladies gents not that
happy about you being here but I've got
a little something for you because we've
got a brand new sponsor and it's called
sons and sons focuses on men's physical
health in particular lads the one thing
we don't often talking about which is
the old Barney
absolutely it's hair loss treatment and
what sons do is they've got three online
consultations with GPS although let's be
fair in the present climate every
consultation of a GP
is now online and they also deliver
direct to your door medically proven
products that help reduce and treat hair
loss and over nine out of ten men so you
get the Barnett looking like this not
looking like constant in their
reasonably priced there's no contract
you pay monthly with no hidden charges
all you have to do is take the
consultation less than two minutes and
then the pharmacy will deliver to your
door within three days so guys in order
to show hair loss news box go to
www.youtube.com for ten pound and you'll
get hair like this and not like my
lovely co-host who is desperately
thinning on top I said I didn't actually
have to say that I just saw something I
want just to popped into my mind one of
the things that I've been thinking about
as well there's this in relationships
between men and women there is this
sense that on the one hand the woman
would like to be able to influence the
man to do essentially whatever she wants
but neither hand I have some personal
experience of the fact that if a man
kind of stands up for himself so shake
and pushes back against that that can be
actually quite perceived as quite high
value by by their female partner yeah
what's that all about so there's a thing
called testing in the red pill community
you can call it testing the bond there's
a lot of different ways that you can
talk about it but let's say I have a
partner I do and I say you know tell me
you love me tell me you care about me
you can do that all day long that's very
cheap talk right but if I make a
scenario incredibly unpleasant for him I
act unreasonable beyond belief and then
I see okay where does his patience break
right is it 15 minutes is it 20 minutes
is it two hours I'm a very patient
partner so I try not to do this but I do
understand that I am in this kind of
this
of scenario so on the one hand if he's
incredibly patient with me I think this
person is very committed and heavily
invested in me but a man whose high
status is necessarily not going to put
up with this much right and so when you
when you test somebody in this way when
you ask them not to just tell you how
they feel but you actually say I'm gonna
engineer a scenario this is obviously
stuff that totally doesn't occur
consciously and I'll tell you about when
I'm most likely to do it then you
actually see okay there's a certain
threshold at which you no longer and I
can put up with where I'm at or what I'm
what I'm imposing on him and at that
point you think okay this man has got
either other options or as high status
there's this thing called the polygyny
threshold model so the idea is that
women either had a choice of having a
monogamous relationship with a somewhat
lower status man because 80% of
societies throughout evolutionary
history of human societies have been
somewhat polygynous that means very high
status men occasionally had more than
one partner whereas low status men
generally had one partner and there were
some men who were out of the game
entirely we call them again discontent
doesn't like have like half of 1% of the
world as his descendants because he
mastered the art of sensual massage it's
because I see he killed thousands of men
had sex with thousands of women and
often beaver the women that no longer
had men to protect them where was I at
sorry I like that but you were
essentially talking about the fact that
most ate over 80% of society yeah so
this is one thing that happens is that a
woman who is with a very high-status man
is sharing that man often times with
other women throughout evolutionary
history even now to some extent right
and so he has other options so he's not
going to put up with as much it's just a
very simple market forces kind of model
it's very very simple and so if he's not
gonna put up with as much she thinks
okay he's got other possible options and
therefore it's it's a circular thing but
if he's putting up with less stuff that
means that he has other options when he
has other options he puts up with less
and I'm taking some of the red pill
stuff that that people really rail
against and I'm saying how can women use
this in a way to understand better
themselves and their relationships with
men and what's answer to that question
[Laughter]
there's a counter-argument to that and I
can imagine the progressives probably
somebody with an indecent issue with
three colors in their hair of
indiscriminate gender would be saying he
hasn't had his breakfast requ is it
carbohydrate or nicotine but who was
saying hang on are you just teaching
people especially women to be
manipulative yeah when they pivot of is
a dirty word but we're all manipulative
so so I talk about babies babies cry
when they don't get what they want you
know there's a reason why babies like to
be held and bobbed up and down it's
because if you're holding a baby and
you're bobbing them up and down there's
nothing else that you could possibly be
doing that's right your baby knows that
they have all of your attention when
when you're doing that and do people
call babies manipulative I don't think
they do because babies are unaware of
what they're actually doing so the idea
is that you're not manipulative unless
you actually are aware of what you're
doing and if you shame people for being
aware of how they're being manipulative
then they're just more they're running
more to matically yeah they just be
manipulative all Matt ik pilot
manipulation that people tend to do is
actually much worse than any kind of
conscious manipulation that you could
engage in and the thing the problem
people have with conscious manipulation
is it's because it's a characteristic of
sociopaths and Psychopaths right so I
cabeza sociopaths are very aware of how
they're manipulating other people but a
lot of what we're doing in relationships
of the people is manipulation and my
view is that if we're cynical about our
own behavior then we can actually figure
out what's the best way of getting what
I want as opposed to what the automatic
way that I'm trying to get what I want
so interesting thing that happens in a
lot so I was in a long-distance
relationship for a long time and now
I've moved in with my partner we're
getting married in a month time actually
and so one
thing that I noticed is that when we
reconnected again after we've been apart
for several months I was really angry
with him in some sense like I would go
see him or he especially if I was in one
place and he was leaving I would feel a
desire to be punitive towards him about
small things before he left and what's
happening basically is that my evolved
psychology doesn't know that he's not
leaving because he wants to go off with
somebody else or that he's not leaving
because he's leaving me and abandoning
me it's because he's got to work
somewhere else or I have to leave right
and so when I see him again
none of the romantic stuff that he had
done none of the phone conversations we
had we're really mapping on to him in
person
Jeffery your assignment it's like it's
like you know like a cat hissing at its
reflection in the mirror like I
understand consciously what's going on
it's like when you see a optical
illusion you can understand consciously
what's going on but you still see it and
so even though I know consciously what's
going on I know that I'm gonna do a lot
more kind of testing the bond if I
haven't seen my partner in a month time
because in some sense I'm gonna be
saying I want to test you are you still
invested in me are you
what's your status like right now right
I want to test all those things because
what he says what people say is cheap
talk people can say whatever they want
and so I think humans have evolved to
test one another in this way and you see
this it's funny when people say that
this doesn't happen with adults because
it happens with children all the time
the idea is that we kind of grow out of
it but when a toddler throws a tantrum
or a baby cries or any you know you see
if you go in anywhere where people are
taking care of children you see children
just completely manipulating adults and
in some sense it was actually not in
some sense in almost every sense adults
really cultivate that they really
cultivate their child's ability to
manipulate them
oh absolutely as a former teacher I used
to see it all the time
my favorite question was that my parent
used to ask me was how do I stop my
child from using the iPad and I would
get that at least twice every parent see
then you know I would say well it's very
simple you just take it off
what I can't do that because they'll get
upset this is this is interesting
there's a really great Brian Kaplan book
called selfish reasons to have more kids
where he talks about it was actually a
book I think he wrote to trying to get
his wife to have two more yeah yeah and
he says you know most of what happens
with children and their their
educational attainment that stuff is
actually just genetic so if you just
give them like a nice nurturing
environment you don't neglect them and
you don't amuse them then they'll
generally turn out fine but because of
this progressive idea that the
environment matters so much there's
become a signaling about how much you're
willing to invest in your kid I think
some of it has to do with like
attachment parenting you know you don't
want to be pushing your kid away and a
carriage you want to be wearing them all
the time this kind of thing and I
recently read an amazing essay from BF
Skinner about something he designed for
his second daughter which is called an
air crib and he says that he got down
taking care of a baby down to only an
hour and a half a day but you know we do
encounter andriy so essentially he
designed this air crib and it's got a
plastic sheet in it and the air quality
inside is regulated for a newborn at 86
degrees I'm gonna build one of these
things it's regulated at 86 degrees and
then the air quality is filtered through
right and then the baby only has to wear
a diaper it doesn't have to wear any
clothes because if you look at parents
dealing with children they're like
taking on tiny cardigans pulling off
tiny cardigans putting on their tiny
shoes taking off their tiny shoes
they're always dressing them up and
doing things
Skinner basically says you just keep
them in a temperature controlled
environment with the air filtered and
they can wiggle-waggle
any way they want newborns want to
always be moving around not newborns but
babies want to always be moving around
and there was this incredible rumor like
total urban legend that his daughter was
miserable and that she tried to kill
herself because she lived in this crib
most of the time until she was about two
years old and what Skinner is saying is
that they looked at all of the stuff
that parents do for children and they
said what is necessary for the child
psychological and physical well-being
and what isn't and when it wasn't
necessary for their well-being they just
cut it out right and they ended up
totally fine so what I think people are
doing when they like real
housed their kids in this way of course
tony'll disclaimer I have no kids yet
I'm you know you're going to see me in a
couple years potentially and I'm gonna
be like one of these you know
babywearing women you know like my boob
is constantly in my kid's mouth and
they're like ten years old no idea like
what kind of that's the scary thing
about motherhood actually like that
crazy woman from gamma throwing people
through the movies on a scary thing
about motherhood is that I have no idea
how fundamental my personality change is
going to be so scary but and that bleeds
it's really nice young because you would
you we touched on it earlier about how
we are machines who are designed to pass
on our code yeah so really are we just a
slave to our hormones when you and you
said yourself about motherhood that you
don't know how you're gonna behave
yeah exactly that's that's the really
scary thing about it weird I don't know
if slave is the right word
but I would say that we are definitely
you know we are determined and luckily
you know we can change our environments
like I can you know I have some decision
about who I spend time with other
environments and influences have on me
but in some sense I have no control over
that because that's a process that's
going to happen and I'm going to be
beholden to my hormones I mean you even
find this in day to day life that you
can feel anxious or depressed and you
don't don't know how to hack yourself
you don't actually know how to change
how you feel and there's a lot of really
great stuff about this there's a really
good book out boy Randy Ness he called
good reasons for bad feelings and he
talks about mental health and mental
illness from this Darwinian and
evolutionary perspective and I just
think it's incredibly important to think
about yourself in this way if you think
about yourself
or the machine that's designed to
perpetuate your code or that's designed
to perpetuate your code not just through
direct reproduction but also potentially
for caring for family caring for friends
building a good reputation all these
kinds of things then you will have a
much better understanding of why you
feel bad why you feel good what's
working for you and and what isn't and I
think a Darwinian perspective does have
an incredible promise for improving
individual lives if we understand it
well
well one of the interesting like tidbits
of information you mentioned in the book
is that the strongest predictor of an
argument between reading in a
relationship is blood sugar levels
that's right yeah so people are
essentially hockey because they haven't
eaten basically yeah yeah but low blood
sugar is yes so this is an interesting
feature of punishment so as I said if
you want to get somebody like if you
want Frances to stop frowning you've got
my full undivided attention you like put
a shock collar on him and you could
shock him every time he frowns can we
get one of those let's go for tomorrow
man actually doing a really quick easy
way of doing yeah if you want him to
stop and find that that's fine I'm sold
another way to get somebody to do
something you want is to shape their
behavior otherwise right so if you want
to get a dog to sit first you reward
them for looking at you then you reward
them for their bottom moving slightly
towards the ground and then you that's
an iterative process that's actually
much more complicated than just
punishing somebody is so what you see in
non-human animals is that punishment is
often the first course of action so if
you feel bad there's some chance that
somebody around you made that happen
right and so you automatically punish
them you see this in non-human animals
so there's this kind of sadistic
experiment they did where they put two
rats in a cage once tied up ones not and
they electrified the floor and what
happens when you electrify the floor the
one rat attacks the other rat-free rat
attacks and tied up right yeah that's
right the free right attacks tied up
right just in case it's a tied up rats
ball all right and you see this you
think you think well we're smarter than
rats no we're not smarter than rats
because if I'm hungry I'm gonna be
[ __ ] to whoever's around because it
might be their fault that I haven't been
fed yeah well we're taking you out for
lunch
it's definitely gonna feed you so so
this is what you know one thing that
happened then you also see this like
it's very funny this there's a kind of
meta punishment that happens so this
this guy that I was friends with we were
out to dinner and then his wife calls
him up and she's where are the towels
and he said
I put them in the dryer and she hangs up
really abruptly so it was funny because
she wanted him to have done something
wrong she wanted him to have love yet so
that she could yell at him and then when
she couldn't yell at him she was upset
so we also get reinforced for engaging
in punishment and we can actually punish
people for not doing something that
would let us punish them does that make
sense there's there's this stuff that
there's this these cycles that happen
and I think that understanding your
impetus to punish especially when you're
hungry so one thing that there was a
weird explosion on Twitter recently
about was fasting I think fasting is
really good I think it's really good for
health and I do like a week-long fast or
a 10-day fast twice a year I think it's
really good for you there were lots of
people speculating that have an eating
disorder I love food just fine but
you're not starving
if you have food if you mean you have
food on you so what happens is you
definitely don't want to be around your
romantic partner like the first two days
potentially if you can be but you have
to just decide that you're not going to
talk to each other very much because you
will be incredibly difficult to be
around you will be very very irritable
and part of editability is to punish
kind of whoever's around no matter
whether they've done anything wrong or
not and as part of that like let's say
in a woman's case is it like well this
guy hasn't brought on brought home a
hunk of meat recently really like crude
you know whatever Klain of the beer
whatever that stupid movie is when yeah
we Jeffrey and I do duke about that he's
like I'm sorry I didn't bring you a kill
yeah so this is an interesting thing
about punishment but another interesting
thing about punishment and women is that
women really want men to do stuff for
them because they want to write so I
have an interesting story about this I
had a boyfriend who lovely loved a guy
actually but on my first ever birthday
he came from a family where they didn't
exchange cards they didn't exchange
gifts so for my first birthday that we
were together he bought me a Kindle book
and no card and I tore into him I didn't
want to it was like I just couldn't help
but like I was really I'm very punitive
by Nature
this is partly me trying to control it I
realized what I had done I felt bad
about it but he got me into that that
year he bought me a car it's like the
next day and then the next year it was
my birthday again and like I had almost
completely forgotten about the total
like [ __ ] I had thrown the year before
and then I found out he bought me like a
very nice set of earrings and a necklace
and he got me a card and I was very
pleased but then I realized he told me
that he had gone to the jewelry shop
three separate times they did spent I
don't know how long
picking out a card for me and that he
was incredibly anxious giving me the
gift picking out my gift and picking out
my card had brought him no pleasure
because he was doing those things to
avoid my punishment he wasn't doing
those things because I had been so
delighted when he had given me a card or
that I had shaped his behavior in any
way and you see this with with dogs and
other animals too if you punish them for
not doing a behavior like if you punish
a dog for not coming quickly enough they
will come fairly quickly but you'll see
the ambivalence about whether what
they're gonna do because they're
approaching the person who punished them
whereas if you give them a treat every
time they come quickly
they'll bound over there's no
ambivalence about it at all and the same
thing happens in human relationships
where if you get what you want through
punishment you know if I don't want my
partner to be on his phone when he's at
dinner with me and I punish him for
doing that I don't care why he's not on
his phone I just cared that he's not on
his phone right but if I want somebody
to give me a gift because they love me
then if you punish them for not giving
you a gift
you're gonna get Stockholm Syndrome
you're not gonna get you know which is a
certain kind of but you're not gonna get
the kind of motivation that you want I
was attending a lecture by an education
expert who was talking about reward and
Punishment in essentially getting
children to behave yeah and he was
saying that it's been proven that it's
not how severe the punishment is its how
regular the punishment is so if people
don't children don't behave and
essentially adults as well by how
punitive something is it's if they know
something is going to happen
like if they know they've they come back
from the pub 15 minutes late they're
gonna get the cold shoulder
yeah then if you go absolutely nuts once
every six times
yeah what do you mean they go absolutely
nothing guy there's two guys they're
talking about how they came home last
night to their wives and one guy says
well I got so drunk last night I went
out to the pub and I knew that I was
going to catch hell so I came home I put
the car in neutral I turned the lights
off I snuck up the stairs I was as quiet
as a mouse and my wife still woke up and
gave me total hell and his mate says
well that's funny because I came home I
raced into the driveway I screeched the
brakes I left the lights on I slammed
the door I came up the stairs I slapped
my wife on the ass and I said how about
it and she was still sound asleep so I
think that what you're talking about is
like if you catch hell every every six
times consistent punishment can be
really good I think even just random
punishment can be more frightening
generally people are if they really want
to do a behavior they're trying to get
in through loopholes and I found this
myself
right I'm trying to make a skinner box
for myself to write this book I'm trying
to engineer things where I'm actually
rewarding people for punishing me for
not getting my word count done for the
day I'm actually trying to build in
accountability procedures and it's
amazing to me that we don't have more
kind of these kinds of protocols in
place like there's no way that you can
at work sit in a skinner box with like a
panopticon
we're like somebody's watching what
you're doing because in some sense we
all want to avoid control that's part of
the reason why we buck against
categories that actually can accurately
describe our behavior that's part of why
we don't want to be genetically tested
that's part of why we don't believe in
determinism it's actually because we
want to believe that we have freewill
and we believe that other people can't
control us but to me it's really weird
we don't have better systems to make
people productive if you actually had
like a skinner box for me to live in
right where you could regulate my access
to social media if you could control
every aspect of my a behavior so I could
get what my goals are done in a more
effective way and have more free time I
would absolutely sign up actually having
said this I thought probably the most
productive people on the planet and this
is just a theory and maybe this is
something for people to explore asexuals
imagine how much more you can get done
if you didn't feel the urge every 15
minutes yeah this actually gets us under
Pali so people are always like oh
polyamory you know because I because
Jeffrey's talking about being
polyamorous and I've talked about being
polyamorous it's very funny because
people always think he convinced me like
oh my gosh polyamory must be like so so
complicated and as like yeah monogamy is
also complicated if you want the least
complicated thing just be celibate like
that's if that's its simplicity is what
you're after don't have any
relationships with anybody that is by
far the if you don't want any drama or
complications the easiest use of your
time but yeah I haven't met some really
amazing people who are asexual and I
have wished at times that there was some
kind of ability to change myself so I
could be asexual for some period of time
apparently you know some parts of
child-rearing are like that anyway it's
like another game of Thrones reference
Lord Varys the one who's the you know he
gets all the [ __ ] done and then that
probably a great singing voice as well
but I was going to ask you this you talk
about this urge to avoid control what is
the evolutionary stimulus the
evolutionary rationale for avoiding
other people controlling your actions
okay that's a really good question
that's always what people say when they
want to delay answering a question great
question so each of us has adaptive
strategies right my adaptive strategy
might be to increase my status to
improve my reputation for other people
to think I'm moral etc right and then I
might have a person in my life who has
different strategy so let's say I have a
partner and my adaptive strategy is to
monopolize his resources and his
attention completely and his adaptive
strategy is to give me just enough
resources and attention to keep me
around but also to see many other women
on the side right what he might do is
try to control how much I demand of his
attention and what I might want to do is
punish him every time he doesn't give me
enough attention so that's one very
familiar kind of dynamic that people
have if somebody is able to control you
then that necessarily means that they
will be able to get what they want from
an adaptive strategies perspective
they'll be able to say that they have
better status than you or have a better
reputation than you or that they're more
moral than you so they'll be able to get
over on you potentially and that's why
we're so resistant to control and you
also see this in families right children
tend to be pretty credulous about their
parents up into a point and then they
get very rebellious as teenagers and why
do teenagers get rebellious will you
start to buck against what your parents
want your parents values and your
parents desires for you are going to be
in their best self-interest but your
self-interest as a newly reproductively
viable person as somebody who can choose
your own mates and things is going to be
different than theirs so in every
relationship there is conflict you even
see this in pregnancy right a fetus
actually causes gestational diabetes
because the fetus wants sugar to be in
the bloodstream for as long as possible
so that they can get as big as possible
because the fetus has only one chance to
get big and strong whereas the mother
doesn't want to have Jace national
diabetes she wants her body to be able
to use to have further offspring so in
every relationship no matter how
beautiful and people talk about
pregnancy that way a lot the reason that
pregnancy isn't entirely delightful is
because there is conflict between mother
and fetus and there is conflict in terms
of the end goals in every relationship
and that's part of why you know monogamy
and para bonds
make sense because it aligns people's
strategies you
see this in non-human animals as well
that in species where the males have
multiple females that they're less
invested necessarily in each one of them
oh when I was reading your book they
were it was fascinating all the way
through there were certain moments that
particularly piqued my interest in
particular when you touched on BPD
borderline personality disorder would
you like to go and talk about that yeah
so borderline personality disorder there
is this idealization and devaluation
that's one that's one major component of
it and I'm familiar with BPD
because I've made I had a couple close
friends with BPD and I have a very very
close family member who SBPD there are
funny stories to tell about her that
maybe I'll be free doesn't know at all
will borderline personality disorder is
just stopped from the very beginning so
borderline personality disorder is
called borderline personality disorder
actually because it was unclear if it
was a personality disorder or a more
significant disorder right they weren't
clear about where it actually fell so
it's not at all like dissociative
identity disorder or multiple
personalities
it's actually a disorder where you have
very volatile relationships these people
often have problems with drugs and
alcohol they have problems keeping any
kind of romantic relationship and they
also vacillate very quickly between
idealizing and devaluing their partners
this is someone who looks up to you like
you're God one minute and then just sees
you're the worst person in the world the
next day yes and why wonder why there's
a big part of it is volatility yeah but
if you if you define borderline
personality disorder some people would
argue with me and say it's not more
common in women and then I think it's
much more common in women than men if
you want to say that men have an equal
rate of it you have to define it I think
quite differently so I'll just talk
about women's borderline personality
disorder but I think all women have a
touch of this and I think it's kind of
like hyper training so you can be
incredibly reinforcing to somebody one
minute these women escalate romantic
involvement often
very quickly and like I dated a woman
who had borderline personality disorder
and there was just so many amazing
things about her like she knew
everything about me she had so many
pictures of me in her room university
together the people knew why I was kept
decision for me she knew all my
preferences all my favorite things if I
told her a story once she would remember
it forever right she had an amazing
social memory but I took her to a party
once right we was like a Halloween party
around this time of the year many years
ago and she was just wearing like a coat
in lingerie and I'd literally talked to
somebody else for five minutes and she
left and started walking down a not
dangerous part of Texas but a dark part
of Texas in the middle of the night in
just lingerie and a coat in order to
punish me basically for talking to
somebody else for diverting my attention
for five minutes and women who have
borderline personality disorder also
more likely to do what's called para
suicide to say that they are going to
attempt suicide or threatened to attempt
suicide so what I talked about in in the
book is basically that this is like a
like training and overdrive right it's
these women can be they're really good
at remembering your preferences they
know what's uniquely reinforcing to you
sex is something that's uniquely
reinforcing to men they know how to use
that they know how to use their
attractiveness they're incredibly
compelling in many ways but they can
also be incredibly punitive and the
family member that I have is amazing
amazing at figuring out where the
jugular is of somebody what is like the
worst thing that you could say to
somebody that they're going to be
thinking about for months or years and
this is something else that they're
really really good at and it's it's an
incredible it's kind of a superpower but
in the sense that you know you necks men
or any of these other movies you see
some people have superpowers use it for
good and some people use them for evil I
do think that women have this ability
and if you know about what you're trying
to do with it you can use it to really
strengthen and improve your
relationships rather than make somebody
else miserable and control them
completely but it seems as if there's
traits of narcissism there as well in
that there's similarities between the
two of I got that completely
narcissism there's there's often
commonality with narcissism
I think our system gets to define so
broadly now that I actually don't know
you know there's all these videos on
YouTube and things about like how to
deal with a narcissist and narcissist is
kind of just code now a psychology code
for like any person so narcissism yeah
there is some some degree of it and then
there's this thing called fragile
narcissism which even expands the
definition further where you're like
okay well somebody who thinks really
highly of themselves but sometimes also
doesn't think highly of themselves
that's that's kind of everybody so there
is an aspect of it there in that they
think that they're so important that
somebody else should give over all their
attention and energy and resources to
them so I would say that is actually
accurate yeah and one thing I wanted to
deal with before we wrap up the
interview you talked about the
differences between men and women in in
some of these areas and manipulating
other people or that's a negative word
but influence on other people let's say
one of the experiments you talked about
is that a four-year study I think of
couples yeah found that if the woman was
less forgiving at the end of that four
year period the man was essentially
better trained let's say but he wasn't
replicated on the other side if the man
was less forgiving and used punishment
and whatever the woman didn't intend to
change yeah so what what is that all
about and maybe you know since since the
book is gendered you know towards women
what are some tips for men for how to
behave with their romantic partner if
she is female okay so forgiveness is
just the suspension of punishment so
anger forgiveness is just when you stop
being angry and it's a form of
reinforcement in that in the same way as
if I was just hitting you over the head
I don't know I keep looking at hitting
her head and then I stopped it would be
reinforcing even though me not hitting
you over head right now is not
reinforcing I know why you keep looking
at him because out of the two of us in
your mind he's the only potential
available because you think I'm gay for
some reason in the last interview I kept
saying like well you don't have to worry
about this cause I was like
I remember at the time I was like a gay
Jewish Russian can you tell me about how
you sought asylum and you see this is
the way the going for the jugular and I
was thinking for like a month after that
what are the vibes that I'm sending up
well you said my partner Francis and
then I met Francis you guys should do
something for the female gays right now
but anyway yes I did totally think
constant was gay so and then just yeah
the partner thing is is super weird so
hitting somebody ever they had
forgiveness yes so in this long-term
study they found that a woman who whose
forgiveness increased over time had a
partner whose conscientiousness
increased over time that's a very very
fancy way of saying that essentially
women were using punishment to change
their partner's personalities and
conscientiousness is a major personality
characteristic that she would want in a
husband conscientiousness means that
he's gonna do things that he said he was
going to do he's gonna feel bad when he
didn't do the things that he said he was
going to do and he's also going to be
attentive to your needs those are all
conscientiousness things and so even
though it's unclear how much environment
can change personality it is interesting
that there's actually not more studies
about how much wives and husbands can
change one another's personalities so in
this study they actually found that
women were changing men's personalities
their husbands personalities more than
vice versa and that men's forgiveness
had no influence on women's
conscientiousness now this could be a
novel modern thing you know it could be
that men had more control over their
wives in the past and that dynamic has
flipped or it could be that women are
using these more sophisticated methods
in order to change personality and that
the you know the the method that a man
would have had at his disposal which is
threats has become morally friend and
fun right to put it lightly and so that
could be it I'm not really sure why but
it does seem that women are better at
this particular skill in my view than
men are and the second part of my
question was about so if that way of
influencing doesn't work for men as well
as it does for women what are some of
that kind of tip so you might have for a
man in that kind of relationship where
they also want to you know influence
their partner for the better yeah so
it's a little bit more complicated
most the time men want to influence
women to influence them less so make
sense
so mostly men's complaints about women
in relationships is like I wish that she
would be trying to control me less or
that she would be less interested in the
minutia of my behavior etc whereas women
are interested in actually trying to get
their partner to be more attentive and
interested in responsible things like
that right and so if if a man wants to
train a woman to train him less then he
has to show her that if she engages in
positive reinforcement if she is
reinforcing instead of punishing she's
more likely to get what she wants right
so there's a kind of meta training that
can happen where if a man engages with a
woman if a woman is punitive and he just
caves immediately and this is something
that I've actually trained Jeffery to do
I want to be less punitive and so it's a
little bit like being strapped to the
mast like Odysseus right where like I'll
be in the middle of a like I'll be
really angry with him and like you
better not give me what I want right now
because I don't want you to reinforce me
for this this is shitty it feels bad
I do not wanted to get what I want in
this context and you know similar thing
when we first started dating he has was
he was dating other women
we-we've date other people and I didn't
want him to give in to other women as
quickly either that's an interesting
thing about polyamory so I was like can
you empty out this drawer it's like
midnight so can you empty out this
drawer for me he's like okay it's like
no this is an unrealistic
well not empty the story midnight it
doesn't make any sense he's like okay so
basically I've tried to train my
partners to get me to be less punitive
and more reinforcing and also just less
interested in minutiae I had this
boyfriend who always would joke around
like I'd be like oh you didn't empty out
the dishwasher do you even love me you
didn't you know lock the door do you
even love me and the idea there is
women are using these subtle signals of
whether or not you remember to do my new
things as signals of responsibility and
care and attention and oftentimes people
can just become forgetful so it doesn't
really make sense I'll just give one
last example is that you know Jeffrey is
quite forgetful sometimes especially
about stuff that happened and you know
when we went on holiday together or
social events that we went to together
and it doesn't help at all my first
instinct if he doesn't remember
something is to actually and like that's
not gonna help him remember anything and
I have developed tactics actually to
help him remember things better but have
to read about them well this is a great
thing about it comes very much back to
your question earlier which is about
manipulation versus persuasion or
influence or whatever what you're really
talking about what I hear in that is an
evolved relationship where you're trying
to take control of the shitty part of
your brain and as we all ought to and
manage them better so you become a
better partner to your partner yeah and
I think that's a very healthy thing and
I think we can get caught up too much in
this idea that we're all evil running
around trying to manipulate people in
this conniving evil way actually I think
if you if you want to have a better
healthier relationship what you're
talking about is pretty much the only
way to get there
actually yeah the last question is
what's the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be talking about I think
I've been talking about yeah I think
that this are incline inclination to
manipulate other people about how that
it isn't necessarily bad and about how a
cynical view of our own evolved
psychology is actually the best way
forward in order to treat each other
better and have better relationships
well fantastic Donna thanks for coming
on the show coming again on the show
when is the book out the book has not
got a out date there's not an out day
but we'll we'll be plugging it once it
comes out absolutely follow Diana
Fleischman remind us your Twitter my
Twitter handle is at sentient ists enti
ENT is on you also now have a youtube
account
I have a youtube account I've only put a
couple things up more things will come
up I also have a blog called Diana verse
mmm it's the only thing that could
capture all of the weird [ __ ] I'm into
universe yeah well we'll put all those
links in the description thanks very
much for tuning in this week and we'll
see you in the weeks time with another
brilliant episode take care see you next
week guys thanks for watching guys as
always subscribe to the YouTube channel
click the Bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out and follow us on all the
social media at trigger Potter and also
leave us a nice review on iTunes and
spread the word